he's Mike Leach Mississippi State head
football coach who joins us on the
program good morning coach
congratulations did you watch any
football over the weekend yeah that's
what your producer just asked no i
didn't i entertain myself with my own
football i tried to I I dented I had
over a thousand text messages I dented
that and then and then working on put
together a staff and logistically
getting things in Starkville will you
watch the national title game that's
honestly that's about 50/50 also are you
are you rooting for anybody are you
rooting for LSU since they're in the SEC
or Clemson because they're long you know
I want to see I like a good game I mean
I watch it in particular I want a good
game that's kind of dynamic you know
where there's some action up and down
the field in other words good offense I
don't like those roll over ones and you
know so I don't I would prefer it's not
just kind of a pitching duel type of
deal I'd like to see some some sparks
fly and some you know some dynamic plays
so I guess from that standpoint very
kind of regular fan like but I'm not
partial to either team really when you
look at offenses now like what's the
next and you've been on at the forefront
of offensive innovation here what do you
think's next when it comes to offense
whether college or the NFL
well definitely some will be next
because you know stuff stuff goes in
cycles a little bit I mean it's a
combination of people invent new things
but also something that worked good like
for example the wishbone people put that
on the shelf a little bit nobody's
really stopped it but you know it's sort
of out of style more than anything
and it's in and it is a dynamic offense
I think so I think there's a there will
be elements of that and it's hard for me
to predict but I also think certainly
there's some of these area and other
leagues I think I think you'll see it
polish up I think you'll see people kind
of put their own brand on it a little
bit and then I also think you'll see and
there's been some of this you know you
know Oregon did some of this for a while
when well like when Rich Rodriguez was
at Arizona and we'll Clemson first and
there were some of it where people start
spreading out to run it and you know
just as far as he's as much of the
fields that can be to run it yeah I
think that I I still maintain you gotta
be able to run the football when it
comes to certainly NFL playoffs you know
this time of the year given the weather
conditions and just being able to keep
these offenses off the field like what
the Titans are do doing now it's not for
everybody because not everybody has a
Derrick Henry but I still believe that I
might not be able to match Kansas City
with Patrick mahomes but I'm gonna make
you try to you know stop my offense as
well and you know I like the chess match
there I think a lot of these offensive
coordinators head coaches are probably
going hey we're gonna air it out like
Golden State in basketball hey we'll
just do what they're doing and not
everybody can do it at that high of a
level what do you think of that
philosophy I think it's pretty much true
I don't think it's partial to running or
throwing I think you got to be able to
control the football though I mean like
um you know the you know the West Coast
offense which is really popular for a
while I think I think you have to they
threw it most of the time but I think
you do have to you know when it comes to
controlling the football first downs and
third down conversions are the important
thing most people don't realize this but
I've led the nation in
time of possession before which I took
virtually no pleasure in waiting for
distinction but I mean the most
important thing of all those points the
greatest form of ball control in the
worldís points and anybody that doesn't
believe that there are those that don't
know they don't believe that are idiots
which is I mean nobody's going to give
up points oh so you score seven points a
in one play and and and the guy on the
other sideline would agree to this - in
nearly every situation I can't think of
any wouldn't where you go hey look you
know I was trying to control the ball
there you know I know you've been there
and tried to do that hey what do you say
we take the points off the board and we
screw it and put the ball on the 50-yard
line would that be okay I mean he'd let
you every time because you know with
points you get not only do you get the
points you also get the amount of time
it takes the other guy to match those
points and then you're gonna get the
ball again and keep it you know what you
can to keep it as long as possible but
with that said overall I think you want
it you want to first downs third down
conversions and most plagues that's what
you're really dominating somebody if you
have the most place and in the most
first downs and good through down
conversion so nobody's gonna erase the
points on the board nor should they he's
Mike Leach the new head coach at
Mississippi State you taught a class at
Washington State insurgent warfare and
football is that right yeah that was
pretty fun are you going to do that at
Mississippi State
I haven't crossed that bridge just yet
it would be fun to do we did it during
spring you know because with recruiting
and all that you gotta make sure I'm in
town so we actually did during spring
football and we do it every Wednesday
but I had just fantastic guests you had
Dudley
very you know my portion that was easy
enough because I'd already watched a
bunch of film that day and then you know
but you know had one guy Mike
Baumgartner who was a state senator
there in Washington he would describe
you know what insurgent warfare is and
I'd you know illustrate it with some
football examples like you know we're
trying to protect this we've got to
attack that you know but look out for
that you know just kind of how it would
go and then we are guest speakers we're
just outstanding
we had Jack Thompson the former the
throwing Samanya quarterback from
Washington State he talked gave a great
talk
we had a guy from homeland security that
was instrumental and in busting the shoe
bomber and the Boston Marathon bombers
guys that had been to Afghanistan and
Iraq we had a Air Force survival
specialist so you'd leave these this
deal with more questions and answers you
know I mean because it was really
fascinating stuff and I said we were
lucky that we got to host these guys so
after class we could ask him a variety
of questions and and learn more about
their lives and so yeah I mean it was
very mentally stimulating as far as what
you heard what you learned and then ok
and as soon as they left of course I
thought up 20 questions I wished I'd
asked you know
have you gone to little Dewey's barbecue
I haven't heard about it they talked
about you know the broadcaster's on TV
going there and that that it was a big
time and I look forward to doing that
can you give me the timeline here how
quickly did this happen with Mississippi
State because it felt like the Giants
now reportedly said Joe judge was
probably going to go to Mississippi
State at least that's what we hear and
then the Giants swooped in and then
decided to make him their next head
coach and then how did that play out
timewise for you
I think that's pretty accurate like
[Music]
somewhere between minutes and hours you
know it was pretty fast
I mean wait so they call him and they
offer him the job and then you get a
call I don't know on that I don't know
on his part but I do know that they
called me up and they said hey we'd like
to we'd like to fly in there and talk to
you I said all right
when are you thinking he says this
afternoon afternoon because yeah we got
a plane we could drop in there well you
know and that's pretty much what
happened and then then a day went by and
they flew in again so yeah way it was
quite sudden it was you know a lot of
meetings and long meetings out on the
deck and Key West and when you're on the
private plane to go into Mississippi
State Starkville did they teach you
about the cowbell or were you well aware
of the cowbell well I was well aware the
cowbell there's some distinctions on the
cowbell they're very important one is
you can't to buy your own cowbell it has
to be given to you and then the second
thing is when you shake the cowbell it's
very important to hold it over your head
to get the most noise out of that
cowbell because after all that's the
point
and then so with a few brief
instructions on the plane I came off
that plane ring in the cowbell well it
should be fun you and Lane Kiffin and
the SEC to go along with all the other
characters there at I look forward to it
and we appreciate your time and
congratulations again coach well he's a
fun guy and it sure seems like a
conference where everybody loves
everybody and
you know and I'm a friendly guy so we'll
see how it goes you know Thank You coach
that's Mike Leach he's the new head
coach at Mississippi State this program
brought to you by Mercedes AMG be
prepared for whatever comes your way the
OL new GT 4-door coupe because life is a
race visit your local dealership for a
test drive today if you missed any of
the celebrity interviews from any week
here in the Mercedes AMG man cave go to
the Dan Patrick show app watch and
listen from inside Mercedes AMG mancave
Mercedes AMG driving performance for
more Dan Patrick show tune in to
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV stream
for free on BR live or download the Dan
Patrick show app
[Music]